[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le mardi 5 novembre tout de suite
les titres de cette édition
la venue de nicole belloubet attrape la
ministre de la justice et garde des
sceaux était au commissariat de la ville
située au merisier c'est l'un des
quartiers de la reconquête républicaine
choisi par le gouvernement dans le
dispositif de la police de sécurité du
quotidien le premier grenelle des
violences conjugales s'achèvera le 25
novembre mais quelques propositions sont
d'ores et déjà connus aujourd'hui les
conclusions des grenelles locaux ont été
remises nous verrons quel travail a été
mené dans les yvelines
et puis une livraison prévue avant la
fin de l'année bmw va avoir un nouveau
siège toujours à montigny le bretonneux
où le groupe automobile est déjà
implanté interview de vincent salim ans
président du directoire de bmw cette
information pour débuter les présidents
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
devant l'assemblée nationale pierre
bédier patrick devedjian était
auditionné aujourd'hui par les députés
pour parler du projet de fusion entre
les deux collectivités on rappelle que
ce processus de rapprochement a été
enclenchée entre les deux départements
depuis 2016 on reviendra largement sur
cette information dans le journal de
demain
trois jours après l incendie du
chapiteau de l'arche trois ministres
étaient à chanteloup-les-vignes ce matin
aux côtés des habitants et en soutien
aux forces de l'ordre celui de
l'intérieur christophe castaner la garde
des sceaux nicole belloubet et le
ministre près et du ministre de la
cohésion des territoires julien de
normandie les membres du gouvernement
qui ont dénoncé l'acte criminel les
violences du week-end dernier et une
annonce l'état participera à la
reconstruction du lieu culturel chiffré
à 800 milles euros il devrait donc
s'associer au département des yvelines
qui par la voix de son président s'est
engagé hier à financer entièrement à les
travaux du chapiteau et dans cette
affaire on rappelle est que deux
enquêtes ont été ouvertes les deux
personnes interpellées dont un mineur
ont été mises en examen et écrouées à la
ministre de la justice a poursuivi sa
visite seul dans les yvelines nicole
belloubet s'est ensuite rendu au
commissariat de trappes au coeur de l'un
et des quartiers de la reconquête
républicaine ce dispositif vise à lutter
contre la délinquance renforcer le
contact avec la population et aussi les
partenariats avec les élus et les autres
administrations de l'état
manon varaldo la ministre de la justice
nicole belloubet s'est rendu au
commissariat de trappes dans le quartier
des merisiers zone appartenant au
quartier de reconquête républicaine trap
est l'une des quinze premières villes de
ce dispositif annoncé en septembre 2018
un travail mené avec les élus la police
de sécurité du quotidien et de l'état
le quartier de reconquête républicaine
est un dispositif qui a pour but de
lutter contre la délinquance et les
trafics en déployant progressivement des
moyens de police supplémentaires
là où il ya eu des renforts dans le
domaine de la police et où il ya un
travail de vraiment d'articulation avec
les procureurs de la république bien
nous arrivons me semble-t-il à apaiser
une situation
la police de trappes a fait part à la
ministre de la justice des dernières
interpellations des 1550 vols contrôlés
ou encore des dernières prises 100 kg 7
de cannabis de 109 grammes de cocaïne ou
encore la découverte de 14 véhicules
volés ils ont également interpellé la
garde des sceaux sur l'augmentation dès
violences
sur les personnes dépositaires de
l'autorité publique supérieure à 20%
notamment la nuit c'est bien cela qui
crée des réactions de la part de
personnes qui refusent cette présence de
l'état républicain
la justice doit aussi intervenir pour
prendre en charge les personnes qui
commettent de telles infractions
tout cela doit je l'espère peu à peu
parvenir à créer un véritable climat de
confiance ça dispositif de quartier de
reconquête républicaine se poursuit
jusqu'à la fin 2020 dans 45 autres
quartiers sélectionnés
nicole belloubet qui a également parlé
du sujet de la justice des mineurs une
réforme de l'ordonnancé de 1945 sur les
mineurs a été adoptée entrée en
application le 1er octobre qui est
entrée en application le 1er octobre
dernier je précise enfin que la garde
des sceaux a achevé son déplacement dans
les yvelines à la cour d'appel de
versailles
[Musique]
129 129 femmes sont mortes sous les
coups de leur conjoint ou ex conjoint
depuis le 1er janvier 2019 ça fait déjà
plus qu'en 2010 huit ans on en comptait
121 une des féminicides que le
gouvernement veut ton digues et pour
cela il va lancer un grenelle contre les
violences conjugales on en parle avec
deux invités en plateau puisque les
conclusions locales 1 de ce grenelle ont
été remises aujourd'hui marielle savina
bonsoir alors vous êtes la déléguée
départementale aux droits des femmes et
à l'égalité des yvelines et frédéric
marc simon soir la directrice et
cofondatrice de woodside qui est basée à
saint germain en laye on rappelle que
cette association accueille accompagné
prend en charge les femmes victimes de
violence ainsi que leurs enfants donc on
va parler du travail qui a été mené dans
les yvelines avec vous juste avant d'en
parler marylène iapichino bonsoir de la
rédaction de tv 78 dès le 3 septembre
dernier date du début du grenelle des
mesures ont été annoncées mais grégory
et dès son lancement 10 mesures
d'urgence ont été prises je rappelle
quelques unes 5 millions d'euros pour la
création de 1000 nouvelles places
d'hébergement d'urgence
la possibilité de porter plainte à
l'hôpital dès le 25 novembre date de fin
du grenelle la création de procureurs
référence sur la question des violences
pour que les dossiers soient ce soit
traitée sous quinze jours et la mise en
place effective du bracelet anti
rapprochement après mais aussi avant
condamnation
ce dernier a d'ailleurs été adoptée à
l'assemblée le 12 octobre dernier
nous sommes donc à 20 jours de la fin de
ce grenelle au niveau national des
propositions sont déjà ressorti la lnr
effectivement les 11 groupes de travail
composé de représentants d'associations
et de l'état de proches de victimes
d'avocats ou encore de professionnels de
santé ont réfléchi autour de plusieurs
thématiques 60 propositions ont été
remises et présenté le 29 octobre
parmi elles la mise en place d'un
protocole clair dans les commissariats
et gendarmeries pour améliorer l'accueil
des victimes avec également une grille
d'évaluation du danger l'inscription
dans la loi de toutes les formes de
violence pour ne pas oublier les
violences psychologiques et d'emprise
sur les victimes
aujourd'hui seuls les violences
physiques elle harcèlement moral sont
répréhensibles pénalement la création du
statut d'enfant victime il existe déjà
un statut d'enfant témoins mais en le
transformant en victime
cela permettrait à ce que le parent
agresseurs doivent répondre devant la
justice des préjudices causés aux
enfants une redéfinition de
l'indemnisation des victimes
pour lutter contre l'emprise économique
des conjoints violents sur leurs
victimes
enfin le renforcement de la formation
des professionnels susceptibles d'être
en contact avec des victimes de
violences conjugales
les effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie les professionnels de santé
les représentants syndicaux et les
responsables en ressources humaines au
sein des entreprises seraient concernées
par ces formations et pour les médecins
une évolution du secret médical est
envisagée avec la possibilité pour
professionnels de santé témoin de ces
violences de les porter à la
connaissance des autorités sans l'accord
de la victime
merci marianne pour toutes ces
précisions et on rappelle un ce numéro
et d'écouté gratuit et anonyme le 39 19
alors les propositions un des grenelles
locaux je le disais on été remise
aujourd'hui des grenelles locaux qui ont
été menées dans les différents
départements de france dont les yvelines
frédéric mars me tourne vers vous pour
commencer vous étiez plutôt mitigé
au début de se tendre grenelle des
violences conjugales avec les premières
annonces du gouvernement est ce que deux
mois après ce que le constat est même où
est ce que les premières propositions
qui ont émergé sont satisfaisantes alors
elles peuvent l'être puisque c'est des
énoncés de propositions il faut après
les appliquer si tu veux un peu le même
problème
je pense que là je préfèrerais parler en
ont au nom des victimes puisque c'est
les victimes qui peuvent le mieux parlé
de ces propositions est de mieux
finalement validé si ces propositions
sont effectivement leur réel besoin
on parle de logement par exemple est ce
qu'aujourd'hui le logement
l'augmentation du nombre de logements
paraît essentiel pour des victimes ou
est-ce que c'est pas l'éviction du mari
qui est qui parle et qui pourrait
paraître plus importante d'autant plus
que quand on est dans les violences
conjugales
il a évidemment l'impact sur les enfants
ces enfants qu'aux victimes où on va
dire victime tout simplement qu'il faut
déscolarisés si la mère doit se déplacer
dans un logement puis les conditions de
logement ne sont pas idéales pour
l'instant et je suis vraiment intéressé
par l'application de tout ce qui se dit
dehors évoqués dans ces grenelle qui
demande beaucoup de travail aux équipes
de terrain mais nous rejoignons avec
plaisir évidemment les concertations qui
sont faites et qui nous remettent un peu
en lumière dans cette problématique de
santé publique
des concertations elle sa ville un peu à
l'image de ce qui s'est fait pour le
grand débat national voilà qui est
déclinée au niveau local il ya une
réunion qui s'est tenue le 13 septembre
dernier au tribunal de grande instance
de versailles l'objectif c'était de
rappeler les actions en cours et on
pouvait le dire on peut le dire c'était
le point de départ de ce grenelle dans
les yvelines
oui tout à fait il faut rappeler que le
grenelle c'est avant tout un processus
de concertation et de collaboration le
13 septembre était le lancement du
grenelle 78 et nous avons depuis le 13
septembre mis en place trois groupes de
travail sous pilotage de la préfecture
et du parquet donc groupe de travail où
étaient conviés les associations le
frédéric bien évidemment et était
présente donc un premier groupe autour
plutôt de l'évaluation et du repérage
deuxième groupe sur les procédures
judiciaires et les dispositifs de
protection est le troisième groupe qui a
été
on va dire le groupe où les idées on
était peut-être les plus les plus vives
parce que c'était autonomie et
accompagnement vous imaginez que dans
l'autonomie il y avait également la
question du logement de l'hébergement et
des enfants précise ce chiffre en 1626
procédure pour violences conjugales qui
ont été traitées par le tribunal de
versailles en 2018 vous l'avez dit donc
les acteurs autour de la table c'était
les associations les représentant de
l'état dans le département
l'association représentant de l'état
centres d'hébergement d'urgence nous
avions également les collectivités
territoriales faut pas les oublier
conseils départementaux conseil
départemental avec les territoires
d'action départementale et puis nous
avions également des réseaux locaux
comme des associations qu'on peut avoir
en milieu rural il faut pas oublier que
les yvelines soit aussi un département
rural mais prête avec main c'était votre
crainte le début que les associations
soient finalement ignoré dans ce temps
de de grenelle des violences conjugales
alors je vous pose et de la question sur
deux plans au plan national puisque
l'association accueille des femmes de 51
départements ce qu'au niveau national
vous avez été associé selon mme ndèye
fall était associé pas du tout et
d'ailleurs on sent on en est très
content aujourd'hui puisque on préfère
rester en dehors d'un d'une concertation
nationale qui ne nous satisfait pas tout
à fait on est très content de rejoindre
la concertation départementale puisqu'un
un sens pour nous d'abord parce qu on a
une très belle représentante en
l'occurrence marielle savina qui
oeuvrent sur le terrain qui passe son
temps à essayer de faire que les gens se
parlent et c'est un peu ça l'objectif
parce qu'on ne peut pas dire aujourd'hui
qu'il n'existe rien c'est simplement en
fait un état des lieux et on constate
qu'il ya énormément d'associations où on
est énormément de connexion à faire
aujourd'hui et c'est le mieux travailler
ensemble qui me paraît absolument
indispensable le fait que les
départements le conte et des femmes qui
viennent de 51 départements
alors là c'est une réflexion nationale
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe quand un
auteur part dans un autre département et
que la femme reste dans les yvelines
donc la problématique nationale elle
doit prendre en compte qu'un auteur
comme une victime ne restent pas
nécessairement dans son bassin de vie et
comment on traite ça juridiquement ça
c'est important
et comment ça se gère d'un point de vue
national avec une géolocalisation qui
est dépendante quand même de la
situation
la base le lieu de vie des enfants
en fait dans les violences conjugales
l'occurrence vous avez un peu répandu
dans votre votre réponse au niveau local
le constat est plus satisfaisant dans
l'indre et travail me dit tu sais si ce
déjà la satisfaction c'est de pouvoir
rencontrer retrouver en fait des
collaborations qui se met en place et
qui sont visibles maintenant je crois
que le travail de marianne savina et est
énorme parce qu'elle fait se rencontrer
des gens qui aurait pu très bien ne
jamais se rencontrer
simplement c'est une volonté
effectivement on va dire d'un
département
je pense que ce département il ne reste
pas suffisamment il n'est pas mis en
lumière il n'est d'ailleurs pas présent
du tout du tout dans le grenelle
nationale c'est ce que je vous avais un
peu expliqué alors qu'il a énormément de
particularités il a une n'a rien à
envier de département il ya eu quatre
homicides 4 sur le département
féminicide pardon sur le département et
puis il ya énormément de manifestations
de violence dom départements pourquoi
nous ne sommes pas d'un point de vue
national dans la représentation des
concertations nationales qui ont pu être
mises en place pour terminer maria de
sabina les premières propositions qui
ont pu émerger au niveau local quelles
sont elles
la première en effet frédéric a répondu
je pense qu'avant tout c'est un état des
lieux et la volonté et la nécessité de
coordonner l'ensemble des acteurs qu'ils
soient des acteurs locaux que ce soit
des services de l'état ne serait que le
besoin de coordination donc l'idée c'est
de créer un réseau des réseaux c'est à
dire que il ya plusieurs raisons un peu
partout dans les yvelines s'assoit au
nord au sud au centre de notre
département
donc l'idée c'est de créer de réseau un
or un sud où va pouvoir se rencontrer
l'ensemble des acteurs se concerter
faire des guides de bonnes pratiques et
faire remonter au niveau du réseau qui
serait le réseau a piloté par la
préfecture et le parquet en tout cas des
bonnes initiatives qu'on pourrait
renforcer et développer ce que l'idée
c'est ça existe fondamentalement ça
existe nous avons tous il faut juste
mettre en musique et faire de la
synergie
donc ça c'est premier point c'est la
coordination des acteurs nous sommes
également en train de mettre en place un
protocole de main courante
enfin un protocole de prise de plein
dans les hôpitaux donc avec une
expérimentation à l'hôpital de
versailles avec une généralisation au
mieux en 2020 sur les autres hôpitaux en
tout cas de nos départements
pour citer après plutôt la question de
la mobilité c'est vrai que la question
des mobilités elle est importante c'est
quand nous habitons à mantes et qu'on
doit aller à l'unité médico judiciaire
de versailles
compliqué de se déplacer donc on pense
initier des bons mobilité donc des bons
taxi alors c'est pas une nouveauté un
mois je me suis inspiré bien sûr de ce
que fait mes collègues dans d'autres
départements ma collègue de 95 par
exemple je salue mou le réseau aussi du
droit des femmes qui font beaucoup de
travail aussi sur les au département
donc voilà pallier à la carence des
dispositifs pour faire en sorte que nous
allons vers la victime et faciliter l
son besoin d'aller vers les dispositifs
spécialisés donc voilà les bons les bons
taxi pourrait être une réponse simple
efficace facile à mettre en place et pas
onéreuses
voilà pour ses premières propositions on
précise que le travail va se poursuivre
le grenelle et des violences conjugales
se poursuit jusqu'au 25 novembre mais le
travail au niveau local ce que vous
m'indiquiez tout à l'heure va se
poursuivre même bien au delà merci à
vous deux je dirais oui je finirai et
dire que les forces de police ont été
souvent mise en lumière mais mal et
qu'aujourd'hui le département que soit
la gendarmerie la police est très actif
sur sa formation sur la rencontre avec
les victimes et je voudrais vraiment
mettre en lumière vint finalement d une
institution qui a quand même été pointé
du doigt
largement et puis le conseil
départemental qui maintenant est très
actif sur ce sujet là merci frédéric
marty merci à marielle savina d'être
passé en plateau pour parler de ce
grenelle des violences conjugales au
niveau local
après octobre rose le mois de novembre
est lui consacré au cancer masculin pour
l'occasion le prostate tour était de
passage à la clinique des franciscaines
à versailles aujourd'hui informé sur ces
pathologies méconnues et prévenir le
cancer de la prostate est le premier
cancer masculin le reportage de maryland
à pishin c'est bien une prostate géante
qui a été installé sur le parvis de la
clinique des franciscaines à versailles
en ce mois de novembre dédié au cancer
masculin
le public est invité à s'informer sur
les pathologies de cette glande méconnus
comme la dénomme de prostate
ça leur permet de bien comprendre
que quand il ya un flux rynair qui doit
passer dans un canal qui est comme ça
complètement bouché et va avoir du mal à
s'écouler
la dénommée c'est juste une augmentation
du volume de la glande sens par le
concept
le cancer est lui situé sur la partie
périphérique de l'organe
il est dépisté à l'aide d'un toucher
rectal et sur une évaluation de
l'évolution du taux de psa antigène
spécifique de la prostate il se fait à
l'aide d'une prise de sang
si ces deux mesures présentent des
anomalies on réalise une irm puis des
biopsies avant de réfléchir à un
traitement des traitements justement
expliqué lors de conférences pour cette
journée spéciale donc your quatre
possibilités la première c'est de ne
rien faire parce que l'on sa prostate
peut être parfois considéré comme un
vieillissement normal de la prostate
la deuxième c'est la curiethérapie donc
là ça consiste à mettre des implants
radioactifs directement prostate le
troisième c'est la radiothérapie externe
et le dernier ça change on trouve peu
d'informations dans les journaux donc
j'en permet d'avoir une idée de au moins
poser quelques questions y avoir des
réponses plus le cancer et des saules et
au mieux il se guérit le dépistage est
recommandée dès l'âge de 50 ans pas fait
80 ans les hommes ont 80 % de risques de
présenter des cellules tumorales
alors pour poursuivre la sensibilisation
le prostate tour fort un prochain arrêt
vendredi 8 novembre à massy économie les
entrepreneurs du réseau yvelines
business club avait rendez vous
aujourd'hui au golf de la boulie à
versailles il recevait vincent saly mon
président du directoire de bmw france
l'occasion pour nous à d'évoquer avec
lui la stratégie du groupe automobile
mais aussi l'implantation toute
prochaine du nouveau siège à montigny le
bretonneux jules colis pour les moyens
techniques
seize mille mètres carrés implantée à
saint quentin en yvelines bmw france va
bientôt changer de locaux un nouveau
siège pour le constructeur allemand à
quelques mètres de l'ancien dans le
quartier du pas du lac à montigny le
bretonneux qui va regrouper sur un seul
site trois entités du groupe bonjour
vincent salim en mauges au gorille canal
et président du directoire de bmw france
la livraison de ce nouveau sujet est
prévue pour bientôt alors elle est
prévue pour la fin de l'année
et globalement les premières entités les
deux premières entités pour déménager au
mois de janvier et bm nous les français
donc la bm du logo france la filiale
commerciale va déménager début février
la mi-février tout le monde ça tout le
monde sera installé à la mi-février
alors les travaux avaient débuté début
2018 ce sont 100 millions d'euros en
tout qui ont été investis par les france
vous parliez des entités donc bmw france
et qui était déjà montini bmw finance
qui était installée à vue en guerre pas
très loin et alphabet france qui est
implantée à rueil-malmaison dans les
hauts-de-seine pourquoi réunir les trois
entités ont un seul site en fait tout
simplement pour s'adapter par rapport à
l'environnement économique par rapport
aux nouvelles façons de travailler
on nous étions trois entités trois
filiales du groupe allemand installé en
france mais avec trop de silos et c'est
vrai que la distance géographique ne
facilite pas la la la la la façon
d'optimiser nos de développer les
synergies et donc il était important
qu'on puisse se réunir dans le même site
c'est pour ça que le bmw group a montré
vraiment beaucoup d'intérêt sur le
marché français en investissant beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup d'intérêt sur les
yvelines parce que c'est un site
stratégique et en réunissant à
l'ensemble des entités pour qu'on puisse
renforcer les synergies tous ensemble
mais rester sur le territoire de 50 ans
débutera pourtant il ya beaucoup de
constructeurs qui sont implantés qui ont
leur siège sur ce territoire la plupart
des constructeurs sont dans l'ouest
parisien et dans les yvelines
parce que c'est assez stratégique malgré
tous ses proches des équipementiers
aussi ce qui est un élément important
et puis c'est facile d'accès et donc
quand on réunit nos concessionnaires ou
quand les cantons les fait venir sur
paris c'est aussi très bien qu'ils
puissent avoir un accès rapide
on imagine son nouveau siège qui
répondra aux enjeux actuels ceux de
l'environnement c'est aussi en termes de
bien-être des salariés les mettre dans
les meilleures conditions de travail
complètement on
c'est à la fois les mettre dans les
meilleures conditions en termes de façon
de travailler mais aussi d' optimiser
l'efficience et la collaboration
l'aspect collaboratif des collaborateurs
c'est vraiment très important donc on
est bien évidemment sur des open space
mais on est même sur un fax office en
fait il y en aura pas de bureau d'abord
il n'y a pas de bureau fermé mais en
plus même les bureaux physiques ne
seront pas affectés puisque chaque
collaborateur pourra s'installer où il
le souhaitera n'importe quand à partir
du moment où ils travaillent de manière
vraiment transversale transversale avec
ses collègues parce que son nouvel de
nouvelles manières aujourd'hui de
travailler
ce sont pour moi et pour nous en fait
pour l'ensemble de bmw group france ce
sont les meilleures façons de d'être
efficient et de pouvoir vraiment
travailler avec une une efficacité
totale avec l'ensemble de ses
collaborateurs au sein d'une entité mais
aussi les collaborateurs d autres en kit
et même de développer continuer la
stratégie de bmw en france justement bmw
en 2018 en france dans l'hexagone ce
sont près de 85 mille voitures
immatriculées
quinze mille motos et scooters ce qui en
fait le premier constructeur en france
sur le marché premium la stratégie c'est
de continuer ce qu'il ya de nouveau
projet qui est alors il ya toujours de
nouveaux produits je suis simplement
rectifier un petit sheldrick 85000
immatriculations il ya quelques mini en
fait il ya eu à peu près 27 mille mini
bmw group en france et bmw ces mini et
bmw motorrad vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure et la mobilité est en train
d'évoluer
l'environnement économique et
l'environnement du secteur automobile
est en train d'évoluer et il est
important de développer les nouveaux
produits c'est pour ça qu'on a lancé la
nouvelle serre est une il ya peu de
temps on a on a eu au mois de septembre
on a vraiment une offensive produit qui
est très très forte et on développe
aussi les services donc on travaille sur
la connectivité au sein des voitures ont
travaillé sur la voiture autonome
aujourd'hui on parle plus d'assistance à
la conduite mais c'est un élément très
important
on travaille beaucoup sur la voiture
électrifiée et on travaille sur les
services partagés et aujourd'hui dans
paris vous pouvez payer votre parking
avec parts now qui est une application
qui appartient bm de les groupes alors
le véhicule électrique le véhicule
propre justement en 2018 5726 voiture
produit par bmw
si une augmentation de 26 3% par rapport
à l'année précédente c'est de continuer
dans cette voie pour l'année 2010 9 et
celle 2000
c'est indispensable à fin 2010 9 on en
rit immatriculée dans le monde le bmw
group
cinq cent mille véhicules électrifiés en
france la bmw i3 est un vrai succès on
va lancer en octobre 2013 donc c'est une
voiture 100% électrique
on a encore fait plus de 40 % de
progression en immatriculations sur le
mois d'octobre de vous voyez qu'il ya
beaucoup d'intérêt et on prévoit à fin
2021 d'avoir immatriculé 1 million de
véhicules électrifiés dans le monde
parce que ça fait partie des nouvelles
mobilités ça fait partie des enjeux
environnementaux aussi et il est
important que nous puissions être
présent sur l'ensemble des motorisations
y compris la motorisation électrifié
alors une question sur le lieu qui nous
accueille aujourd'hui le goal de la
boulie adversaires vous aller témoigner
devant les entrepreneurs de livres in
business club pourquoi c'était important
pourquoi avoir accepté cette invitation
parce que c'est important de pouvoir
rencontrer les décideurs les managers
d'un département qui est très important
comme le département des yvelines
et puis il ya une petite anecdote et au
golf de bouli c'est un élément important
aussi parce que bmw très investi dans le
sport est très investi dans le golfe les
partenaires de la fédération française
de golf qui est installé à peu de
kilomètres d'ici vous savez au golf
national
on a été partenaire de la ryder cup qui
a été un événement planétaire
fantastique qui a eu lieu dans les
yvelines l'année dernière on est
partenaire de l'open de france qui a
lieu aussi à
au golf national et donc il est bien de
pouvoir rencontrer les décideurs et
échanger avec eux sur les nouvelles
mobilités moi aussi sur l'environnement
économique mais de façon informelle au
sein de ce club
et puis de pouvoir parler de l'avenir
aussi merci marc sens aliments et je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
directoire de bmw france merci greg ce
dernier sujet avant de vous quitter
après dix semaines de récolte la saison
des pommes s'achève dans les vergers de
plaisir les visiteurs ont profité ce
week-end des derniers rayons de soleil
pour recueillir les pommes qui reste sur
les arbres fruitiers reportage de marie
l'ania piccino et de mathilde domini
dans les vergers de plaisir la
cueillette des pommes touche à sa fin
anne-cécile cultive une douzaine de
variétés dans les deux hectares de ses
vergers trois de ses 12 variétés se
démarquent plus que les autres auprès de
ses clients
la royale galal c'est la pomme connu par
tout le monde
croquante juteuse sucrée après dans ce
verger lie à la golden et puis
lidar est parce qu elle se conserve tout
l'hiver une saison compliquée pour les
vergers qui ont subi la canicule cet été
grâce à l'appui du mois d'octobre les
pommiers ont pu reprendre le dessus même
si quelques dégâts persiste
typiquement les dégâts liés à la
sécheresse et toutes les pommes qui sont
tombés
au sol toutes les trois semaines bruno
vient remplir saga jette dans les
vergers
un rendez vous indispensable pour cet
amoureux de pommes qui ne se voit pas
les acheter ailleurs qu'ici j'aime bien
cuire mes pommes c'est des belles pommes
et si elles sont moins traités dans le
commerce au moins faire aussi
puis a le plaisir de la cueillette pour
mélanie la cueillette des pommes est
l'occasion d'une sortie en famille
habitant de plaisir elle est venu en
vélo avec ses enfants et son mari pour
cueillir ses pommes préférées
on a pris des granny smith donc ce sont
les pommes vertes plutôt acidulées on a
appris aussi des jonagold très sucré et
aline légèrement acidulée plutôt à
croquer pour la plupart des visiteurs
les pommes se dégusteront seul mais
seront aussi transformé en compote en
tarte ou même en crumble
il faudra attendre août 2020 pour
consommer à nouveau des pommes cultivées
localement c'est la fin de ce journal
dans un instant les prochaines
expositions les prochains concerts et
spectacles à retrouver dans l'émission 7
8 culture présentée par aurélie rose
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]